asking for permission to enter.
Whether that be by way of
knocking on the door or ringing
the doorbell or what have you.
Issue here is an issue of issue
of customs. What is customary?
The prophet he says to us that
knocking on a person's door
which is essentially it is then
you're knocking because you're
seeking permission to enter,
seeking the attention of the
People in the home, he said,
this should be three times If
you are granted permission of
entrance, then enter and if
not, you should leave after
three times. and the prophet
also said
and
[Silence]
when when a person puts up a
home with walls, right? The the
point here is that these walls,
they're not impenetrable. You
could, you could break through
the wall. The point isn't to
keep you physically out. The
point is to provide privacy for
the people inside the home. And
so, when you seek permission to
enter someone's home, you're
essentially asking permission
to look inside of the home,
right? So, let's say you're
outside. Some people, you know,
they have a window or
glass on the side, you know, of
the door or little pieces of
glass in the door, what have
you, right? You shouldn't be
looking inside of those pieces
of glass. What can I see? What
can, you know, sometimes,
sometimes the glass is frost,
frosted. We call it frosted
glass but on the sides, it's
clear glass. There's a
strip. You know, you shouldn't
be looking inside of that strip
to see what you can see inside
a home that is haram because
you haven't been given
permission to look inside yet.
And so when you knock on a
person's door you're not just
asking for permission to enter
physically but you're also
asking permission to look
inside. To see. And so we
understand from this that
essentially it is haram to look
around in a person's home
without their permission. Okay?
That goes for even if they let
you in the into the home. You
know, you go to the house, you
knock on the door. As we
mention in previous classes,
the prophet would not stand
straight in front of the door
when he'd knock. He would stand
off to the side of the
entrance. So, as to not be able
to see inside, okay? you
shouldn't be standing in front
of the door as soon as it
opens. You're seeing inside. It
should be that you would knock
or ring the bell and stand off
to the side. Even when you're
granted permission to enter,
you know, knock on the door.
Guys, guy opens the door. Come
on in, right? Maybe he's
walking you through the hall.
Maybe he's walking you to the
kitchen or walking you to
another part of the home. You
shouldn't be looking all over
the place when you're in there,
right? You should only be
looking in an appropriate place
within the confines of that
permission that you've been
given. You're walking down a
hall, maybe there's a little
door cracked open. I wonder
what's going on in there, you
know? This is not correct. This
is impolite, it's rude, and
it's obnoxious. A person
shouldn't be doing that. When a
person enter a person's home,
they're respectful not only to
a person's furniture and the
walls but to a person's privacy
because a person has a right to
privacy. When is in his home
and elsewhere as well.
Wasa Then A
[Silence]
right? They were made out of
very the walls were made out of
very thick, draped wool, right?
Or something of the sort.
Oftentimes, the home is very
small. You don't have to knock
on the door very hard or you
don't have to, you can just
stand outside the door and
speak and the person inside
will hear you and so, a man
came to the door and he asked,
just he approached the door of
the prophet and he
And so the prophet had a man
there. And he said, go outside
to this brother and tell him
how to properly seek permission
to enter. Tell him to say,
assalamu alaikum So, you begin
with a salam and then you ask
permission to enter. So, the
man overheard this conversation
and he did that. So, he learned
what was appropriate The point
here that Ibn ul Kaim Rahima
Allah is making is that number
one we learn that a person
shouldn't exceed three times.
Right? A person should not
exceed three times. You knock
on the door or you ring the
bell, whatever it is, three
times. You're pretty sure that
they heard you. You shouldn't
push it more to where they have
to to where they're in a
position where they have to
come out and say, hey, you
know, not now. That's an
uncomfortable position for
yourself and for the for the
person put in that position.
So, a person needs to
understand that a lack of
permission is a type of
rejection. It's basically like,
this is not a good time and
there's nothing wrong with
that, right? and so, the
prophet mentions three times.
Now, of course, this may vary
wildly based on the
relationship that you have with
the person. based on the
customs. So, for instance, if I
go to a person's door and they
have a camera a ring
camera. and I ring the door and
I'm sure that this person saw
my face in the ring camera and
they I'm there, right? That's
enough. One time is enough at
that point. I don't have to
repeat it three times. One time
is enough. The point here is
that you have become mostly
sure that they heard you and
that they chose not to answer
the door, that's enough, right?
and the and the opposite is
true as well. Let's say you
speak to someone on the phone
that you're very close with and
he says, yeah, man. I'm I'm
cutting wood down in the
basement. Come over, right?
Just ring the bell when you get
there. and so you get there and
you ring the bell and you hear
the power saw going on
downstairs and you ring the
bell three times and he doesn't
hear you. Can you ring the bell
more? Yes. Because he told you
to come over and obviously he
can't hear you because he's got
machinery going on, right? So,
the point is is it's to be it's
to make sure that yes, the
person heard and communicated
by lack of engagement that this
is not a good time, not an
appropriate time. That's all
that's intended here with this.
Another thing that we've
learned is that when we ask
permission to enter, we're not
just asking for permission to
enter, we're also asking
permission for to look and so
we are not to look and to
invade another's privacy
without their knowledge and
that's in general, in general,
it is not permit to invade a
Muslim's privacy without his
knowledge, right? This is what
we refer to as a and a is not
halal. It is haram. In all
cases. Spy. Spy on someone or
to invade their privacy without
their knowledge. A Muslim has a
right to privacy, people. In
general, all all people have a
right to privacy and to spy on
them in any way. Whether that
be hidden camera or hit a
microphones or tapping into
their phone or even picking up
their phone and looking in it
without their permission or
even if a person, you know,
gives you their phone to to
make a phone call and you start
flipping through the tabs to
see what's going on in there.
All of this is haram. All of
this is impermissible, right?
And if you look hard enough
into anyone's life, you're
going to find things. Isn't
that the case? If you spy on
anyone, most 99. 9% of the
time, you're going to find
skeletons because we're all
human beings and we all make
mistakes. For this reason, the
prophet he mentioned in
that if the leader starts to
spy on his citizens or starts
to spy on his subordinates he's
going to, he's going to It's
going to spoil them. He's going
to basically harm them and make
them worse. Why? Because number
one, if they feel that they're
being spied on, this is
extremely stressful on a person
and changes the way a person
behaves normally. If you, if
you, if you suspect you're
being spied on, right? Isn't
this going to change your, your
behavior? Let's say you're a
person that, you know, you, you
You haven't done anything
outwardly to to cause suspicion
What constantly you're being
accused of something and spying
is a type of accusation, right?
It goes back to because when
you think ill of someone,
that's when you start spying on
them. By default, everyone is
guilty. Therefore, I'm going to
spy on them. This is what that
means. And so this changes
people's behavior and second of
all, that were upstanding,
you've now looked into some of
the underbelly of their life
and some of their mistakes that
are between them and Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. You've
exposed them And so now no
noone in your in your mind is
going to be truthful. No one in
your mind is going to be
upright. And so spying is a
major sin in Islam. It harms
people. It's very harmful. And
if we look at ourselves
honestly what right do I have
to spy on someone else? I mean,
am I free of sin? Am I free of
mistake? Am I free of secrets
to where I should be looking
down at other people and spying
on them? an ant under a
microscope? I'm not free of
sin. I have no more moral high
ground to to be spying on one
than they do to be spying on
me, right? And for this reason,
the prophet alluded to this
this here that those who spy on
others, you have no right to do
that because you're just as
guilty as others are. Right? He
says, in a narration collected
in a
and Abdullah Omar
[Silence]
do not follow up and look for
their mistakes or indeed
whoever looks to expose the
mistakes of his brother, Allah
will look to expose his
mistakes. Whomever Allah looks
to expose his mistakes, he will
he will shame him and expose
him even if he is in thee,
safety of his home. So, it's
important that we understand
that when we look to expose our
Muslim brother, Allah may look
to expose us. And vice versa.
If we look to conceal the
mistakes of our Muslim brother,
Allah looks to conceal our
mistakes. The prophet says, in
a narration that most of us
know. Muslim and
Muslim
he said whoever conceals a
Muslim's mistake his mistakes,
the things he's ashamed of, his
sins, his miss, his misdeeds,
Allah will conceal his mistakes
in this life and the hereafter.
So, who of us doesn't need
Allah conceal our mistakes.
We're all guilty, all of us,
right? None of us has the moral
high ground to point down at
anyone else. We're all guilty
in our own way and we all have
skeletons under in our closet
and even Abbas he said,
Ibn Abbas said, Essentially, if
if
[Silence]
and smelly, right? But we
shouldn't be spying on each
other as Muslims Be concealing
each other's faults. and we
should be trying to avoid
seeing each other in our most
vulnerable state. Some of the
when they would go
sit with their teachers before
they would go every time they
would give charity. They would
give something in charity and
make dua, oh Allah, conceal our
teachers, faults from us. If
you have a teacher, a leader,
somebody that inspires you,
everybody has faults and
mistakes. You want to make sure
that you see the best that that
person has to offer. And so
they would make dua that Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala keep that
person as a person of esteem in
their in their hearts and in
their minds. So that they
continue to learn. And continue
to better themselves. and this
all roots back to the issue of
can people change or not? Yes,
people can change People can
even change their nature. The
nature of a human being is to
be oppressive, to be ignorant,
to be arrogant, to be greedy,
to be and all of these things
can be changed. With thee, with
the light of the Quran, The
light of faith. And Allah
[Silence]
his name or what he's most
known by. Whether it's his name
or his or his nickname.
Whatever people know him by,
right? And a person shouldn't
say me, who's at the door, me,
right? One of the companions
did this and the prophet
corrected him for it. And even
if you know the person, you
should say your name, who you
are.
and it's been collected by
in a also
that the prophet said a man's
messenger to another, is his
permission. Right? So, if I'm
in the house, I'm upstairs or
wherever and I send my son or
my daughter to the door and the
person opens the door. You
don't have to wait for me to
come. As long as a person has
sent someone else to answer the
door on his behalf, then that
is enough.
Then he goes in to mention the
issue of implied permission
implied permission. For
instance, if I say, okay, come
come over to the house right
now. You know, and have lunch
or something. When you come, do
you have to still ring the bell
and ask permission to enter or
no? It depends on what is
implied and this all roots back
to one issue and that is
implied permission. Implied
mission. You have permission
which is explicit. Someone
says, this or that, you stay
within the confines of that
permission and then you have
permission which is implied,
right? Let's say you have a
friend, he doesn't have a wife
or anything. He stays in an
apartment. You go over there,
you stay there sometime, you're
close. He gives you a key.
right? You have implied
permission. You can go in there
without him knowing, right? You
in your mind what is
appropriate and what isn't and
so there is such a thing as
implied permission and there is
such a thing as specific
permission. If you're given
specific permission, you stay
within the confines of that
specificity and if you are
given implied permission or
general permission, you stay
within the confines of what you
know to be appropriate.
[Silence]
The
The scholars mention of them
Allah. that a sneeze
is a sign of activeness. It's
an indicator of an activeness.
Does a person sneeze while he's
sleeping? No. Person only
sneezes when he's awake. And
not only that but it kind of
accelerates the body to sneeze.
Contrary
to yawning, yawning
and articulate laziness,
tiredness, disinterest. It's
viewed often as being, as being
rude, and many situations,
whereas sneezing is not
considered rude. Yawning is.
For this reason, the prophet
tells us, that Allah loves
sneeze, sneezing, and he
dislikes yawning He says,
hence, if any of you were to
sneeze, he's to say and if he
says it is a binding obligation
upon every Muslim who hears him
say to reply to him
Allah. And in another
narration, prophet says, and if
others say to him, Allah, then
he should say to them, Allah,
He continues to say, and
yawning is something from a
Shaitan and so if a person, if
one of you were to yawn then he
is to try his hardest not to
allow his body to yawn, right?
Lock his jaw, whatever it is.
And if he is unable to
completely suppress this yawn,
then he
should, then he should
cover his mouth when he yawns.
this is not part of the
narration but this is in
another narration especially in
salah. A person yawns. There's
a couple of things having to do
with yawning.
the
[Silence]
that we all know Then a Shaitan
laughs at this. This is amusing
to him. Because it's
humiliating to a person. It's
obnoxious and likewise, if a
person yawns, they are to try
to suppress this yawn as much
as possible. If they are
unable, then they are to cover
their mouth when they yawn. The
scholars mention different ways
to cover the mouth. Some
mention it should be with the
left hand, some mention it
should be the palm outwards.
The point is, is that a person
should cover his mouth?
Likewise, when it comes to
sneezing, the prophet
is and what he taught his
companions was to sneeze into
the sleeve or to sneeze into
your clothing. To a napkin or a
tissue. The point is to not
openly sneeze and the worst is
to sneeze into your hands.
Because you sneeze into your
hands and now you know, grab
things and handle things and
[Arabic recitation]